foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming at Lord
addicts here man we welcome to another
episode of The Attic show we talk about
the past present future gaming I got I
got Dart with me man what's going on
dirt
what's up my brother
and then we got we got slow mo Our Guest
uh you know last week I felt like I
needed to get slow-mo on here man I feel
like I need to get slow on here what's
going on slow mo
yo chilling man I I last week I was like
I was in the chat like I wanted to be on
so I'm glad I'm here now you know we can
uh I mean not the same conversation but
we can definitely uh chop it up and uh
and get into these topics you know what
was the topic that you wanted to speak
on last week I'm kind of curious I don't
even remember man I'm I'm old man I just
I don't remember things very well
whatever it was I was excited
I was doing a lot of talking to the chat
oh man
yeah so appreciate for coming through uh
you know hopefully a bit cloud and Forte
would show up eventually you know
eventually eventually they'll be here
let me let me oh no Forte he's here
oh man he went let's leave this shirt
man sleeveless shirt
what's going on Fortune
I don't think he cares no you don't look
like he could hear us
are you there Forte
yo there you go
all right so now
we're starting the show man we we got a
I got a pretty good interesting show for
you guys it's been a little bit of a I
wouldn't say a slow week but considering
we went from like some of the best news
weeks to this week it is a little bit of
a slow week so we're gonna talk about
the PlayStation VR too I I personally
believe it's killing it's on Vibe you
know we got information on it's not
backwards compatible and now they
showing all this like 4K stuff in the
trailer look I'm not saying none of this
is real but when I see stuff like this I
say that looks expensive then we got uh
GTA 6 leaks you know I want you guys
overall experience with that uh then we
got everyone's favorite thing
is gaming dying because I I see a lot of
this this stuff going around the uh you
know especially this community where
they feel like because of
microtransactions Etc et cetera that you
know gaming might not necessarily be
dying but it's going in a way worse spot
especially with the rise of mobile so
you know I definitely want to get in on
that a little bit so you know I got
Forte here he's on the phone so uh you
know uh he is his intro I I don't want
to be too rude
you you there before time I'm here what
up though man how you doing so how how's
the how's the Lord how's the the Lord's
work the iron Lords everything involved
with that been treating you uh well IOP
for those who don't know we actually
launched a tick tock account that I'm in
charge of that entirely uh so it's been
um
it's been interesting to learn another
algorithm you know I spent like probably
six seven hours the other day
uh just researching how Tick Tock
algorithm works and I don't really got
it down
even remotely but you know I'm learning
man I'm learning uh so no I definitely
don't
I'll be I'll be uploading six times like
man man this is these highlights is fire
it'll be like 28 people look at I'm like
what yeah well what I've learned so far
it's it's more about consistency than
anything like they want they want you to
post more than they want you to post
good content it seems like so you know
if you get a good clip just post the
post the clip in I've noticed that like
music's really important too you want to
make sure you have some popular Tunes in
there uh so you know here is the topics
for today gentlemen because I do have a
little bit of extra stuff in there you
know we'll talk about death loop on Xbox
uh that officially launched in I think
it was yesterday or today yeah soccer
yesterday your job Target
oh my God so you know we're gonna talk
about that and then we're gonna talk
about
2023 in-house it potentially might be
one of the best years in gaming in a
very long time uh you know that that
depends if everything actually formally
gets yeah that's how you turn your
camera a little bit yeah that's if
everything actually gets announced you
know how Stuff always gets pushed back
and stuff we got to see exactly how that
works out so you know I think we think
first we're going to talk about the the
video industry dying man I I'm kind of
curious to hear you guys opinion on this
I know that
I would say that the focus of the
industry has shifted away from your
standard hardcore Focus it's not
necessarily on that anymore I feel like
it's uh it's on a majority of stuff now
so I you know we'll start with Forte
Forte do you think that with the
direction the industry is starting that
you know maybe it's going to be more
casualized in general like you know you
got free to play games coming up like
hardcore you got uh you know just
microtransactions in general you got the
mobile market coming up hardcore you got
like these big you know expensive press
conferences spinning a lot of the
portion of the conference on mobile
aspects and it's not really hitting it
right for people like us what do you
think Forte uh we've been seeing this
for the last half a decade already it's
it's been heading in that direction
probably since 2013 2014 ever since last
generation started
um you know Xbox started it with the
capitalization of trying to integrate
the Xbox more into the home theater
setting with the TV aspects and NFL and
everything like that you know over the
course of like the last five or six
years all you've seen is a move to just
find out trying to find a way to make
more money instead of really diving in
on a craft of what Gamers truly want
when it comes to like you know games in
general uh now some people are going to
tell you that the games that people won
are the games like fortnite like Pub G
like
um or games like or Apex Legends and
stuff where you can uh just jump in at a
free price and put as much money into it
as you possibly want to we started
seeing halfway through the generation
last generation where EA literally
started press references talking about
microtransactions and mobile games and
stuff like that so this has always been
kind of the direction they're going in
the pandemic definitely didn't help that
matter because more and more people that
didn't even think about playing games or
were gamers in a previous you know part
of their life came back to it and they
still don't have time to play games as
much as they want to but these games now
are so tailored for you just to pick up
and experience a 30-minute segment 45
minute up to an hour segment and get
your fix and then you're out of there
again so that's the direction they're
just trying to find a way to keep you
coming back daily or at least once every
other week versus that go out purchase a
60 70 title and then make it our money
that way they're trying to find ways to
say well that same person that bought
this one item how do we keep them
spending money and that's where you're
seeing a market go and that definitely
goes towards the more casual side of the
market than any thing
yep oh I think he's on the phone yeah oh
my bad my bad I do agree with you I do
feel like we're seeing more of a casual
audience like more of the masses jump on
than anything like I don't understand
how people could say that the gaming
industry is dying but then you see next
year there's a lot of games coming out
next year like it's just like I think
what we're getting is we're getting
a lot of the delays a lot of you know
buggy games because of the pandemic and
I think we're starting to see them come
out slowly every other game's buggy
every other game's breaking you got
games getting delayed out of the
physical year that they're supposed to
be and I feel like people are mistaking
that
for that's how all we're gonna get like
a lot of the games that's not getting
delayed are the games it's not going to
take as much to actually make
so that's what you're seeing well that's
also part of it the other part is the
fact that there in most people's eyes
the games that they prefer to play
they're not making them as consistently
as they were before it's like there's
like if you are a first person shooter
that's what you like to play yeah
there's a lot of them out there but
maybe you don't like the free-to-play
model when it comes to like the the
pubgs or the Battle Royale and stuff
maybe you like that grounded single
multiplayer single player aspect those
games are a diamond does it you pretty
much got a battlefield you got a Call of
Duty and that's kind of it where it used
to be more games that came out like home
front and stuff used to come out like
that where there was more
um more reasons to like try out
different games because you never know
what's going to stick with you now
you're starting to see less and less of
that and more and more of the stuff that
pretty much anybody can pick up and play
so that's why I think a lot of people
say it's kind of dying it's not dying as
a overall industry history is dying for
a lot of people when it comes to their
preferences and the things that they
like to play and I even see that at the
retail side because people like I'll see
people walking to the store and they're
like hey man what's new this out I'm
like dude what's on your library at home
that you ain't already played he was
like man my library is so thick I just I
just don't know what I want to play and
they're just walking in the store trying
to find something new for them and
things like you know PlayStation premium
and Game Pass are really really good
Avenues to kind of get you with the
stuff that you normally don't play but
you're starting to see a real huge shift
in the way that people perceive the
things that are out there there's a lot
of games to play but a lot of people
aren't like slow-mo backslap that tries
every game or gamey addict that plays
every game that comes out those people
are you guys are a dime a dozen versus
everybody else
all right so slow mo you know taking
this conversation going and
um you know I do want your perspective a
little bit on the free to play because I
know like you've been very Advocate on
like you know split gate when it was out
Fortnight uh so you know because I do
think that has something to do with what
these these uh you know people in the
community are saying that they feel like
gaming is going in a bad Direction
because of this stuff so I'm kind of
curious your opinion on this
yeah I think a lot of the people that
say things like that they are they are
wishing for a time back when gaming was
you just bought the game and you played
it and you played it until the cartridge
broke or the CD broke it got scratched
up or whatever and but that's it like
there was no patches there was no first
day day Zero patches to fix this there
was no updates there was no oh well look
we'll get that campaign to you in six
months you know meanwhile just you know
playing the sandbox for no reason like
there was none of that kind of uh
business formats for a game to be
launched and so they these people wish
it was like that again that's what they
kind of feel like the industry is dying
but if you look at like statistics the
industry is not dying it's actually like
health-wise doing better than it's ever
done before there's more money in the
gaming industry now and it becomes and
there's more money into going into it
and more new Gamers joining it every
single year so it's it's like a train a
runaway train that can't be stopped it's
not it's not going back to the way it
used to be now it doesn't mean that
you're not going to get those kind of
games that you may enjoy but we do have
to understand that like the mobile
market which is 15 like 50 of the
revenue that's generated in gaming is
going to influence the way PC games are
made the way console games are made and
eventually that it will trickle in some
way so like you mentioned split cake
and I you know really enjoy split gate
but that developer
is now decided to move on to a new game
still will keep the servers for split
gay open but no more new content but the
way split gate was was the business
model for it's very similar to like a
hybrid console hybrid mobile uh uh
um format it's a free game like a lot of
mobile games but it's not necessarily
pay to win whereas a mobile it's like
hey you got like 10 great hours in that
game and then now it's like ten dollars
for like three more three more minutes
or ten more spaces or whatever the heck
the game is right it's not like that
necessarily where
split gate and a lot of other games that
are free they they want they want you to
spend money on Cosmetics they want you
to spend money in micro transactions
loot boxes that kind of stuff to kind of
keep you keep the game monetized to keep
it going but that's not going to be
every single game I think sometimes we
get into this people see things they
don't like and they act like that's the
only thing that's out there like
everyone's trying to be fortnite
everyone's trying to be Apex Legends I
think that's their biggest issue I think
people
you got too much coffee canning going on
you got too much I deserve GTA success
but I don't have a GTA product
right right and you're not gonna get
that and I feel like a lot of developers
and Publishers put some especially
Square Enix they're notorious for it
they said 10 million that's that's a
financial loss what do you mean it's a
financial loss
like I don't I don't get that and I feel
like a lot of Publishers they constantly
there's nothing wrong with Chase in the
back but you got to chase the back
realistically and I don't think that
some of these Publishers are
realistically chasing the bag they see
what fortnite's making they see what GTA
5 is making let's see what Minecraft's
making they see what Zelda made they see
how many copies these games sold how
much microtrans is this game and then
the developer and publisher looks at
this like I could do that no you can't
you can you don't got the product to
keep people
going as long as it does you know there
you know I'm curious what's your opinion
let me get these two super chats real
quick and then we're gonna hear the uh
you know uh dirt gold I I I have a
feeling you can have a very uh
interesting take on this flight with the
two dollar super track gaming industry
dying I Blame Halo and Game Pass okay
I'm pretty sure you're you're trolling
uh we're gonna move past that uh Caleb
with the five dollar okay web with the
five dollar Super Chat uh a lot of
people have romance ideas of what gaming
industry and the average gamer used to
be uh to a point I agree with you I'll
get that to that a little bit more when
it's my turn tell me man tell me is
people bugging it's gaming yes quote
unquote die
absolutely not
I'm going to go back to what slo-mo said
at the beginning
um people just have this idea of how
gaming used to be that is going to
continue to be the same way no we are in
2022
it's not 1996. it's not 2006. I always
mentioned how I um saw a picture of
eight people made Super Mario World for
the SNES eight people
that was a dope game it was really good
just to see only eight people develop
that game why I'm saying this is because
we're in a different time where
games are much more expensive to develop
um you know there's so many different
Avenues of of gaming from Mobile to
console to PC to Cloud
um there's a lot of money out there and
and like you guys are right there are so
many copycats going on like yo I want
that that same GTA success I want that
same Fortnight success well in reality
we want a lot of things that doesn't
mean it always going to happen that way
right so
I agree with you guys with what you guys
are saying it's just that
the mighty
when when that when they're seeing these
other games these other companies being
so successful
they want that also so they have to try
their best to to do that and some of
them fail that's like any other aspects
of life if my favorite burger joint all
of a sudden start selling chicken
sandwiches also because every other
restaurant is selling chicken sandwiches
too
yes they're trying to get that same
success that Popeyes had or Chick-fil-A
has but it might not work my work might
not work so at the end of the day
it is what it is of course it's not
dying like slow-mo said it's as
successful as it has ever been but we're
not going to get those
every game is not going to be a single
player Banger like there was in the
1990s we still want to get some
but yes we're going to see less and less
of them unfortunately because I like
single player games but it's all about
the money like any other business
they're going to try to do what they can
to make the most money out of out of uh
their product
Sony is making live service games last
generation people thought they would
never do that or go that route putting
their games on PC and also making live
service games here we are
right so at the end of the day nah man
no the game industry is not dying it's
different
it's different than what a lot of people
is used to but of course it's not dying
at all
yeah I agree with you you know uh come
to come to my point like I think what
you're seeing is not necessarily the
gaming industry is dying it's expanding
there's genres that we didn't see 10
years ago there's different forms of
genre and now you got stuff like uh you
know Forza Horizon Forza Motorsports
like a lot of the time back then some
games didn't apply to you but a lot did
but now these Publishers they're trying
to do as much as they can to take
advantage of as much of the industry as
possible I do think that mobile
is starting to Heap into the into the
the console part a lot especially you
see uh people going towards more of a
of a you know a an x-cloud kind of thing
so I think you know you'll see a lot
more of that
but I just think that if you like a
certain type of experience you're not
going to get that anymore I think that
there's gonna there's still going to be
games like that but you're going to
actually have to you know pick and
choose what you play not to mention
games get more expensive they can't make
these games in two years anymore exactly
so when you add on to the to the time
frame you're going to be waiting even
longer to play some of these games so it
seems like the gaming industry is dying
but all since the games that you don't
like don't take a lot to make don't take
as much time to make so you're seeing
more than the games you want to play
because your games are still in
development for another year into two
um I that's that's why I believe I think
that
we are in an industry now where games is
a service and multiplayer focused games
are keying among all sure people like
Sony they make very good third-person
games but even themselves are investing
in a 10 gives us a service products
and I think they even see like look they
even see the air of their ways you know
what's funny people used to talk a lot
of smack about when Phil Spencer said
that games like Horizon are good they're
great
but they're not the focus of the
industry anymore he never and what's
funny is people said that he was acting
like third person action adventure you
know the Sony formula was was was dead
he never said that he just said the
focus of the industry is The Game's as a
service is that type of service function
because if that was the case then you
wouldn't see hell Play 2 coming out you
wouldn't see right these other games
that they're making like Phil Spencer's
always said
when it comes to that industry that sock
that space he's like he to me he's
always said look we're working on that
but that's not the focus because
Microsoft has taken the it like what
we've been saying we want everything
everywhere we want to sell you game pass
on on your PC on your Xbox uh hope one
day they're gonna try to get it on the
PlayStation and switch they're gonna try
to sell it to you on the smart TVs
they're trying to get that app into
everything and I think they're pretty
good on your refrigerator it's a you're
joking you lying so I already owe your
refrigerator man he's joking I I I
definitely agree I think a lot of the
Publishers are seeing it that way I mean
most recently you can look at EA who was
Notorious for forcing uh developers that
had no business making multiplayer games
and had no uh interest in it but forcing
them to do it anyway they did it with uh
the dev uh that they shut down that did
dead space I can't remember their name
was it visceral
yes uh but but they did it with BioWare
force and BioWare to put multiplayer
into uh games that are primarily single
player RPGs and and most recently like
with the success of Jedi Fallen order
um we respawn entertainment they realize
like you know we can do both we can we
can have our live service content or our
multiplayer content while also having
having single player content that is
like hot like critically acclaimed and
and was a bunch of awards and Garners us
a bunch of attention because they
realize like our reputation was was in
the gutter it still kind of is for a lot
of people for EA that is and but like
this is the way where you can kind of
like balance it you can actually benefit
both communities and so you see them
take like take those restrictions away
from bodywear you don't have to put
multiplayer uh constant in your games
anymore just make whatever you want uh
Dead Space remake is coming out you know
not having a bunch of a bunch of micro
transactions and a bunch of other crap
in there Ubisoft is starting to kind of
see some of that a little bit too you
see where Assassin's Creed they're
trying to cater to both parties trying
to catch the people who like old school
Assassin's Creed with the red and and
Mirage and whatever else that you know
uh Dan Allen leaked and and then they're
also doing their Assassin's Creed
Infinity
which is this big massive MMO like
monstrosity that I think is probably
going to fail but you know it's typical
you saw if they're going to try it
anyway but like you can see this is like
Infinity trying to do both it seems like
Infinity is mainly supposed to be a hub
that you access the future Assassin's
Creed with I don't think that it's
supposed to be like some giant MMO thing
I think that it's supposed to be Hub
that you can interact with and like load
certain levels on other like game play
mechanics of other games like I feel
what you're saying we got to see a
little bit more of like concept and if
that's going to work or not because I
don't think anything like that the
closest thing I've seen to ever do
something like that's the Master Chief
collection and we saw how that went
so
yeah but no there was there was
something I mean about that game what
first came out they were talking about
MMO but I remember speaking with someone
that said that it was it was going that
route but who knows where it ends up
going eventually because that thing is
all that stuff was never supposed to be
leaked out in the first place like this
is information they weren't even that
didn't even want to actually you know
talk about to people outside of Mirage
but because everything got leaked they
ended up having to speak on things a
little bit sooner than they they wanted
to but
um oh yeah I mean we'll see how it all
turns out but regardless like my point
was like
these Publishers are trying to balance
things a bit more we need single player
content we need to cater to that
community that likes that kind of
content but then we also got to be
realistic in that there's younger
generations of Gamers grow and that are
getting into gaming every single day and
a lot of them don't care about that
stuff they care about fortnite Apex
Legends they care about valorent they
care about those kind of games that have
a completely different business model
and foreign
what you said you know you have to
balance uh like the old school Gamers
like us that that love the old school
style of games the single player games
and also some of us love the new style
you know the battle royale's the games
as a service like Destiny and all that
stuff so there needs to be a balance and
I think um like like little addict said
with Phil Spencer you know like people
thought that he was criticizing
PlayStation style of games no he was
just talking about the business in
general and the business in general you
know we've seen it last generation guys
we saw it slowly these Battle Royal
games these games out of service it
started to
take off and these games are obviously
profitable as hell
so I think there needs to be a balance
and I think what Sony is doing they say
okay we we have our great single player
games we need some of our own games as a
service because they were relying on you
know Cod and things like that and we see
what's happening now with the potential
of losing Call of Duty so they're making
their own PlayStation I'm sorry Xbox is
uh trying to balance that also you know
they're trying to do both at the same
time and you know they're building both
and you know this is what it is and this
is the future of gaming you know there's
nothing wrong with it it's
that's different you know when it grows
when it grows you're going to have to
accommodate people who may not like the
things that you like right exactly
exactly you know that doesn't mean that
like you're never going to get the games
that you want it's just that uh when
games when your favorite publisher or
platform decides hey uh we're gonna make
uh a free to play
uh factions we're gonna take factions
from The Last of Us Part uh part one and
we're going to split that off and turn
into this huge humongous I don't know if
it's free to play or not we'll see but
like the huge humongous multiplayer
thing and and meanwhile everybody's like
yeah but we're so Uncharted five right
right
I think that's the biggest issue is the
willingness to do one but not the other
the willingness to do games as a service
games and you know free to play games in
general but act like doing the other
won't make you money as well look sure
certain free-to-play things can probably
buy countries with the money they've
made in in profits but that doesn't mean
all of them are going to and just
because you might make more money with a
successful free-to-play model does not
mean that you can't do a you know a Last
of Us an Uncharted and if it's done well
it's still going to make money but the
problem is business people are looking
at this is like look how much money can
we realistically make can we make money
along over a certain amount of time
frame and if it's not the latter people
get upset oh why is that financially
beneficial is so to me I see the
situations like that I'm like okay so
you're just you're mad that you're not
making a billion dollars and not just a
hundred million dollars okay I got you
know yeah and you know Sony's
Sony's format isn't to have 10 to 12
successful live service games they're
they're being realistic here they know
all those games are not going to be
successful it's going to be some
dumpster fires it's going to be some
construction All-Stars in there it's
going to be some crash and burns
immediately as soon as it hits the
market what they're hoping is that one
or two one of them hit yeah yeah just
hits really good it becomes like an apex
Legends where Apex Legends was like
Shadow launched and it just blew up you
know like they want one of those so they
didn't like it that makes it all worth
it because the amount of money that's
going to generate over a long period of
time will pay for all the games that you
financed and bombed and then some and so
that that's the whole like game plan
really I think well let me interrupt you
real quick just to put a little bit of
context in there I would be okay if
that's the way it goes they're doing
these to put a little cushion if
something doesn't perform well because
that's how Sony used to do it you know
they're bigger games they would use the
cushion for the to uh to do smaller
gains but I feel like especially Jim
Ryan doesn't seem to be interested in
that life it's like if it is a make
money I want it out so that's my my fear
it's like look what's the point of doing
these games with service where it's just
like when you go to those quarter
meetings they're like look this game
didn't make much a whole lot of money uh
but we do want to do a sequel because
see these made a hundred times a hundred
times the amount that it was supposed to
make and then that's like the equivalent
of the board saying well that's seed
thieves like we we want half of that
money so we can reinvest the other half
back in the sea of Thieves like why
would we give you this money to to go
fail again and I think that's the
biggest issue I have is like if they
made that kind of money off free to play
games and they see this model over here
and then some of these games aren't
performing like they used to let's say
they make Horizon three like my
mindset's like look that game's not
making what this game over here is
making so why don't you help this studio
with their content like that's my fear
my fear is instead of using that as a
cushion they just use that to make their
their stuff look better like more
profits more more gain they're trying to
to be more posing to investors that's my
concern
Ed that that definitely kind of feels
like you know the the piggyback off of
that I guess it would depend on if you
get that success would you do with it
because like that's where I am yeah and
that's and I don't mean to make but
saying like EA is like you know doing
everything great but like if you look at
uh games like Haze like Studios it takes
two that won game of the year last year
they didn't really like I don't think
they I think they they pay for all the
costs for that but they didn't actually
take in any revenue for it so like like
that's one of those like Indie Studios
that they help out and a lot of the the
games that there are non-lap service
games that they develop are being paid
for through all the Ultimate Team
microtransaction stuff that people are
paying for through Madden and FIFA so
it's like they take all that billions
that they're generating in revenue and
then they use that to to actually fund
all of their other projects switch and
that was done across the board I would
be a hundred percent for it you know
like for instance we saw especially on
Playstation like days gone like I you
know that division made money so to me I
feel like if a game does well enough it
deserves a sequel it deserves uh the
attempt to improve on the issues that
had in the previous game and to expand
on that existing foundation and to me
it's like when especially you know even
with Xbox with uh you know um
I know people don't like recore but I
felt like that was an example that they
could have built on and it's like I look
at these titles and I'm like look like
if some of your other games are making
vastly the majority more money
that's when I feel like the money should
be shifted to experiment because you
know if they if if Sony wouldn't have
gave the opportunity to make from
uncharged or The Last of Us from Jack
and Dexter to like to unchartered you
don't get the landscape that we're in
right now and I feel like the
the willingness to take those risks is
so far in between now that you don't see
these jumps and ideals anymore
you can go somewhere
I mean okay he's doing something but
yeah my bad I had a I had a phone call
go ahead go ahead Derek Dirk has
something to say I'm not I'm honest here
for Forte man like he ain't said nothing
man oh man this is all this is just
craziness but um
I mean the biggest thing for me It
ultimately just comes back to what do
people actually want like what is it
that you
It's like because these companies are
only going to make things that are good
for them and they know that people are
buying and it's I kind of look at it
just like if you look at consoles and
stuff like they get like Nintendo some
people still love Nintendo some people
moved on from Nintendo and sooner or
later enough people are going to move
away from it where it's just not going
to be as sustainable as it possibly is
now look at that the same way when you
look at games and stuff you know more
and more people are moving away from
certain games that they traditionally
like because first of all they're making
less of them or they're just growing out
of them and they're going into other
games that are more
um pick up and go and that's what you're
starting to see now
um the biggest thing was you guys said
Sony is trying to
um they're trying to build they're
trying to build something that can
replace something that they technically
don't own and they're going the right
way about it some people are going to
say they're doing it a little late
because they've been kind of living off
of third party for the course of the
last 10 12 years same thing with Xbox
Xbox did the same thing they were the
reason that we went into the last
generation the three the Xbox one
generation is because then we're living
off third party they were living
absolutely they were living off Call of
Duty and everything and they felt like
in 2011 when Halo um when Halo Reach
came out they felt like they had a big
enough stake in third party where that
could cover them going forward with all
of their third parties second party
deals and stuff that all disappeared at
the beginning of last iteration and then
all of that stuff went over to Sony and
then Sony's doing the same thing
throughout the whole generation they're
living off third party they're still
living off third party for uh to a point
and now you're starting to see that flip
come back over but the only difference
is instead of Microsoft being the
company that's just try to acquire third
parties in order to just bring them in
and get benefits from them they're
taking them away and saying we're going
to dictate how these games go forward
now Sony has to respond by trying to
find a way to get extra Revenue now how
they go about doing that is basically up
in the air like if somebody's um if some
of these games of service pop off like
you said it only really takes one a lot
of people think it's easy Apex Legend
there was like a whole plan behind that
game the fact that they stealth launched
it they had hundreds and hundreds of
streamers that were under NDA that went
launched day one that talked about the
game like we're not talking about just
little streamers we're talking about
some of your biggest streamers like
ninja I think was one of them yeah ninja
was one
it was just ridiculous they were paying
people millions of dollars to play that
game it was like a million dollar
campaign under EA to get that Game's
name out there
is Sony going to be able to do something
similar to that that's that's the
biggest thing so I always look at this
like initiative is like yeah it's great
that they're doing it but what's the
financial backing of it going to be from
the beginning in order to get it off the
ground to the point where it hits
critical mass like that and maybe they
get lucky in the game just happens to be
really good and people just Word of
Mouth just talk about it and it gets out
there like that and that's probably what
they're hoping that happens but
ultimately we're just seeing a seesaw
PlayStation is reacting to what Xbox is
doing Xbox reacted to PlayStation Now
PlayStation is reacting again and the
thing is gamers are stuck in the middle
because they It ultimately all they want
to do is play games and they just want
to know where those games are going to
be at but the thing is those games are
changing right in front of them the
games that they thought that they love
they don't love anymore shout out to the
homeboy
um Persona I watch this video about Call
of Duty he's a huge Call of Duty fan and
he's like hit or miss on him and this
supposed to be like one of the best Call
of Duties they probably are going to
release with Modern Warfare 2 because
everybody loved the first the original
but he's like kind of mixed on it oh
yeah oh so oh yeah he kind of mixed huh
yeah he kind of me I mean he likes it
but it's like that it's like that that
thing in your mind it's like you're
you're fighting it's you're the
Nostalgia like you like what they're
doing you like this but you really
really don't like this so when you have
fans like that that kind of think like
that and there's more people out there
than you think that do think like that
that's where that problem comes into
um play but ultimately as long as games
are good and games keep coming out
that's all that truly matter but I do
think when Phil Spencer said years ago
that single player games in games like
that are not the sustainable Market I
don't think that he meant like they just
can't be made it's just that those gangs
aren't gonna move the needle
consistently like they used to do in the
past because you can live off of a 20
million dollar selling game you know you
can can live off of that back in 2020
and that's what it's when like 2010 2011
2013. now the stakes of these games the
the amount of people that it takes to
make these games
it's so much higher it's just the last
game it was like 100 million 100 125
million to make a game and now it was
anywhere between 150 to 200 million to
make like exactly endeavors
I do I do feel like
the money's the biggest issue and I feel
like that's all it is
well it's not even just that I think
there's a variety of different reasons I
think one of the reasons that you know
we don't see certain games that you know
we've grown up we've grown up with we
were catering to see for years because
let's be real here you know so us
growing with the industry we were kind
of entitled at that point because we
were actually seeing these games so when
you start taking slowly because let's be
rude they still make the witchers they
still make the fallouts they still make
the star Fields they still make the type
of experiences that we want it's just
well you don't see as much and I think
that's the biggest issue and I think
you're starting to see certain people
pull out of it uh because they can make
more money in Mobile I was a huge fan of
mist Walker they're they're Japanese
developing Studio the original the
creator of Final Fantasy Made that
company they made Lost Odyssey blue
dragon last story and then they left
concerts went to mobile they ain't come
back since and you know I I that that
hurts to be in The Soul Man and that's
what I think it mainly is I think that
you're it's it's a combination between
rehash titles such as Call of Duty
Assassin's Creed uh where you're seeing
these these guaranteed franchises come
back over and over again then you have
on the opposite agenda where uh you have
people not giving Indies a chance that
actually give good quality games because
it doesn't look what the standard of AAA
product is guess who's eventually going
to take these shoes of these bigger
Studios these Indie Studios that grow up
in the AAA studios in the future and I
think that's combination of it I also
think because it's so much easier to
make a game like you know for instance
like you look at something like Pokemon
makes a lot of money I'm sure Forte can
speak on how much that game sells every
year at GameStop and then you look at
something like unchartered
makes a lot of money hey Forte what game
you think makes more money
it's they released two versions of
Pokemon every time okay and what do you
think costs less to make Pokemon easily
so the margins just way higher math
right yeah so it's just like look like I
don't think that the gaming industry is
in any way shape or form hurting I just
think that it's more diverse there's
more stuff to play there's more options
to play I think the reason you see a lot
of free to play a lot of games as a
service pop up is because that is what
makes more sense financially and I think
as the pandemic starts to level out and
then if throughout the next six months
two year you start seeing more
announcements of the games that you guys
want uh a full point on that so let's go
and move on because we were on that for
a lot longer than I anticipated uh so
let's let's talk about death loop on
Xbox who's played it
sucker I'm playing it right now you jive
turkey
talking like talking like oh there man
I played it uh on PC last year when it
came out oh because see that that's the
correct answer slo-mo dirt let me get
these super chats real quick before they
go away
y'all freaking crazy I don't have a PC
oh we got two dollars cheaper from Onyx
dirt TTS green heart what's up bro and
we gotta find out she was from Artemis
what's up fellas after the horrible Divi
in Nvidia 40 series reveal I'm sending a
public uh appeal to the homie slo-mo
come on homie homie uh what was that
about what's that about hold up hold up
he called him out we we need we need uh
what what's that about slow mo
erotimus uh on a weekly basis keeps
telling me uh every time he sees me on
the podcast to come home and what he
means by come home is come back to Xbox
which is funny because I own the Xbox
like I have I'm looking at it right now
on the Xbox series s it's a 360.
I wish oh man
360.
wow why why you gotta be so
disrespectful
man you should play
woo long on my Series S yesterday he was
in the Stream so that's probably why
that game was performing bad oh
because it was because it was so you're
serious I was thinking about that when
you was complaining about he's like this
responsiveness is trash I was like I
thought it ran good on my series X maybe
you got to get one no though he has an S
that's the problem yeah yeah so look so
this this is what happened like
throughout the I don't know if we should
keep letting you talk you or have an S
wow
but like it kept like this this uh
Xbox UI menu box will pop up saying
something is errors something is wrong
and then it will go away and then my
controller would just like completely
flip out and the first time it happened
I literally ran off a cliff and died
it was the very first thing that
happened in wulong I was late with Dan
and then uh it kept happening during
combat and then like you know stuff just
wasn't working correctly it was uh
I mean the game seems cool it's just
that like I don't know for me the demo
just had all kinds of bugs and issues
but I mean it's not that big a deal the
point I'm here to make especially it's
mostly considered I was playing the
division two on my Xbox just yesterday
as well is that I still play when Xbox
arrived there you go oh my God I do want
to recant something that I told slovo a
couple days ago when we were talking
about gpus and what he should do I do I
I do slow-mo think that that that 30
that 30 series card that you were
talking about it's like I need to go
grab that
you might go ahead and grab that car bro
and video out here big tripping day out
here big big trip as though yo listen
man go ahead and grab that 30 series
card find yourself a 30 90. skip those
fourth gen those 40 Gins because um it's
in the cart yeah
I take back everything I said about that
to go ahead and do your thing is it I
haven't I haven't I haven't uh pulled
the trigger on it yet because I want to
wait until I see what amd's got
so back to death Loop
what has been gay
so you guys me and slo-mo are the only
people that's actually played a good
amount of this how much have you play
Dirt
uh about maybe an hour and a half okay
that's a decent amount uh Forte I guess
you're still in the like the prologue
kind of like period though like in that
that time period
I'm at the part where
she's finally uh like what's her name
Juliana whatever her name is yeah she's
very big on pronouncing her name
starting to chase me not
yeah she's very big on pronouncing your
name but last time you played that game
Dirk oh you just played it recently
right last night yeah but I love Arcane
I love uh all of the games and pray
definitely games uh so I'm a fan of
their games and so far it's it's okay
but I'm still early like you know guys
said
um so interesting I think
but no no go slow mo
um
so I played the game like I didn't
finish it um because and here's why I'm
not a big Arcane fan and look it's one
of those things where you can recognize
uh the developer is of high quality but
it's just not for you right it's like I
played prey I played dishonor I'm not
really into like stealth games
[Music]
don't like Dishonored man what what's
going on and and it's just like they're
just not for me which is like like you
know all their games the first person
perspective but they don't play like a
first person shooter like like I like a
first person shooter so like you want
run running guns 24 7. don't you yeah I
mean I want snappy snappy ads like like
I didn't get that was confirmed to be a
bro do gamer continue yeah oh yeah yeah
I I definitely got some dude look look I
I like I like my my other like I'm very
diverse okay but like but some of my
Shooters I'm dude bro all the way you
know like
those games don't really do that I did
think the story was interesting and
definitely but I like that's probably
the best part of it is the story well
and I think a lot of uh Xbox gamers are
going to enjoy playing the game if they
if they stick with it and don't
um
I would say definitely stick with it to
the end but like it's just it's a little
bit different than what people expect
they're definitely different yeah and I
like Arcane all the way Arcane is
definitely different though
I do enjoy
Arcane games uh the only one I didn't
really like a whole lot was prey and I'm
not saying it was bad it's just I
couldn't really get into it too much uh
one thing what I will say is the only
thing I don't like about death Loop is
the illusion of choice but there's not
really Choice there like when you play
in the game it looks like you have all
these choices of how you want to do this
how you want to do that but then when
you actually find because for those you
know it was in the trailer I can't help
it if you guys uh you know we look at
trailers all the time most of you in the
reaction trailers you've seen it so I'm
sorry
um that flute's objective in the game is
to kill all a certain there's like
there's like seven people I think and
the objective is to kill them all in one
one Loop and they give you all these
options they're in different parts of
the place but
pretty much there's only one way to kill
them all in one Loop like you have to
trick people to do this you have to
there's a lot of different like it's got
a lot of in-depth detail and what I like
about what I don't like about it is one
thing is I don't like that they try to
act like you give the illusion of of
choice but at the same time I like how
they break it down so you sit there
you're going through the game you're
figuring this out you're figuring where
this person's at it's kind of like
like a modern Zelda Majora's Mask
that's probably the only the way to give
an analogy for it like a modern Zelda's
Majora's Mask where you have to do
certain things in a scenario to get them
to go to another scenario like let's say
you do something in the morning because
you want that individual to do something
different at night so you have to do
something different to get them there
and that that's the only thing I didn't
like is just because but
death Loop is one of their best games uh
it's it's a fantastic game when you're
playing it's got a lot of it feels like
I don't there's a lot of my peers
especially People review that don't like
death but I don't get that to this day I
don't get that mean ACG argue about it
all the time actually about my love for
death Loop and he just thinks it's like
an average game pretty much and it's
just like
I had to get myself out of the mental
state that I don't like this game
because it's not Dishonored three right
and for the longest time that's what my
mindset was this isn't Dishonored three
screw that game and you know IOP
you know thanks for the people that
watch IOP
guys were on my ass so guess who had to
review that game you know I want to
point this out that
I don't know if you guys noticed but I
don't talk down a lot of games anymore
because you bully me into reviewing it
because I don't do it anymore because it
let's say that Zelda Skyward Sword I
talked smack about that game for like a
year and a half you guys bullied me into
reviewing that game
and I actually ended up liking it but
this is the point we're not gonna be
talking about you you enjoyed that piece
of that that piece of art didn't you and
you know I feel like
death Loop
if you guys got Game Pass go play it you
know uh try it out I think that you guys
would enjoy it I really do I think that
death Lube it just it's like slow-mo
said you know I do think this is a
little bit more stealth
optional than previous games like
Dishonored yeah I don't know about prey
like you can't go in their guns blazing
very easily it's just it's one of those
games where you have to use your
abilities like uh The Visionaries that's
the people you have to kill throughout
the game right they all have powers too
with you yeah and and so what I like
about it is the best thing about this
game is the banter between uh between
the main character Cole and Juliana I
think that's her name that's the best
banter because at the beginning your
Clues you don't know what's going on and
she knows she has all the cards she
knows what's going on she's confident
she's cocky the whole banter is like
that but then after you start learning
more stuff she's not successful in what
she's trying to do then it starts
switching she's the one flipping out all
the time she's the one losing her stuff
all the time and I like the character
development in this game and that's what
was enough to make me Overlook some of
the issues there was issues I felt like
every character they they did like the
the we happy few thing where they put
masks on everyone so I didn't have to
really do a lot of detail on everything
yeah they had to render faces yeah yeah
it's a it's a way of uh it's cheap to
have limitations yeah yeah but at least
they kind of acknowledge it coach
everybody wearing masks
what the hell is up with that yeah
without okay release date
I don't think death Loop is a roguelike
I wouldn't call it a roguelike because
nothing really changes like roguelike is
like presumably generated parts of the
game that's constantly rotated why the
core of the game is still there like
there's only one objective but you use
that generated content to do it nothing
about this death Loop is it considered a
roguelike I don't know if it's actually
considered a rogueliker I don't think it
is but I kind of felt like the marketing
TR almost kind of like tried to convince
people it was or Marcus is like I got
that implication when I first saw the
game I was just like oh man like I I
have this all this freedom and then like
every time I die it'll be like some
things will be different and I can get
like different things and different like
tools to be able to take down these
people and that wasn't the case at all
so uh I don't think that lent towards my
um my lukewarmness with the game at all
but I think some people felt it was
something that it wasn't and typically
when people jump into something and they
they were expecting something different
they usually don't like it you know so I
think that's why a lot there was a lot
of yeah a lot of disappointment it was
definitely some disappointment out there
with the game
and so we got a ten dollar from cobweb
uh probably what's your name we're gonna
move past that man you guys know what it
is
Cal weeb weed is that is that what he
says
call wheat call weave what Nvidia is
doing with the 40 series is just
outrageous no egregious egregious okay
they have two 4080 uh skus but they
aren't even the same GPU died they're
selling a 40 class card as an 80 class
card for 900. what's going on with this
the people talking about people really
upset 70 Class Cars they out here being
disgusting that's what this is I'm cool
with my 3060 TI I'm gonna be real with
you I'm cool 30 60 TI wait wait hold up
when you downgrade it
what you got a 3080 TI you mean right no
I have a 30 60 TI
oh okay never mind yeah I don't know who
are you talking to another addict are
you sure no no yeah no I was thinking
1080 TI sorry what'd you do with your
1080. uh my brother I gave my brother
the PC
oh you gave him that whole PC okay got
it that's what I went I meant 1080. I
ain't know you upgraded to a 360. well
what happened is I I did a live stream
because for the please I don't know
cog's responsible for all the hosting of
the podcast
um you know unless he leaves then I'm
because I everything caucus I have
either something on par or similar uh he
has a better steam deck than I have
because he does the show more so he's
got like the 32 key one I have the 16.
uh so pretty much how it goes is I'm in
charge of all the live reactions so all
the guests that come in all the live
reactions like that's all me on the back
end well we were doing a big show last
year
and my old PC was like I'm done and just
turned off
so it was fine it was just
things needed to be replaced Cog was
like no so I'll send him a PC I ain't
doing this anymore send this man a PC
so uh now that's the PC I have now uh I
could um
I don't know people in the chat you know
I don't know a whole whole lot about PCS
uh you know that's just me and it's not
nothing like against it but I'm kind of
curious if if this is a good PC so I
have I have a AMD ryzen 750 800x and a
GTX uh our Nvidia GeForce RTX 3060 TI
oh is that a good PC
uh the car the GPU is is good for uh for
for 1440p right I ain't doing nothing
more
yeah um how much RAM do you have uh I do
need to upgrade that I think it's uh
it's 8 or 16. I do need to upgrade that
16 seems more likely that's like usually
the standard if you live it off hey we
got a problem yeah I mean I got 16. if
you had my dog you would definitely know
you would feel it in your games
well I don't see here's the thing I
don't play games like that on my PC
either so well he wouldn't be able to
host this stream and do anything
together
you opened up three times on Chrome and
you're you're your whole screen would
just lock up I know man my piece you try
this my PC trying 16 games yes it is 16.
yeah if I say my PC screaming me at 32
gigs of RAM when I got a thousand
windows open it's like what are you
doing yeah yeah six things the minimum
like that that's that's a decent PC
that's a it's a PC that you could do a
lot of uh uh you could do a lot of good
gaming with that you know if you if you
chose to do so
um but though the the that whole
situation with Nvidia yesterday
essentially this is what people are
upset about
they wanted to charge people more for
the 40 70 but they knew if they called
it a 4070
which is typically around their price
range of a 500 to 600 GPU
if they charge people 900 which is
essentially 300 or more this generation
number they charged two years ago for
the same kind of classic car that people
would be upset so instead they thought
that that they could fool everyone into
just calling the 4080. we got 248s the
way they had 238 these last time but the
difference between the two thirty
eighties last time is that they just had
different memory and that's it it was
the same die it was the same exact card
just different memory given to it
this has got a completely different it's
got less cuticles got less everything
except I may be slightly more clock
speed and that's it and it's just not
the same car it's definitely the what
would have been the 4070 but they
haven't announced the 470.
oh they've announced is this 1600.490
a 1200.48 and then this other 48 that's
900 and so everyone's like nah fam you
you not you're not scamming us that's
not really a 4080 and so that's why
people are upset with Nvidia you know
they are getting people
getting people
all right so yeah man you guys really
serious about this conversation 10 super
chat have for cop believe uh the the 40
84 uh 12 gigabyte is on the r d104 81 I
don't know what you guys talk 8104 died
the 104 die is usually the 70 class card
the four 480 16 gig is on the one is on
you read this [ __ ] slow-mo you know what
this is talking about the 40 80 16 gig
is on the ad 103 died the 103 is usually
the 80 class and 40 90 is av-102 they
are Shameless yeah they are they are
famous and they don't care they they
also just lost their best partner EVGA
who makes gpus EVGA just got sick of
being disrespected by Nvidia it just
said we're done we don't work with them
anymore so does that not even making
cards anymore they said screw it
I I do think that's the go uh they're
just negotiating they might end up with
Intel in AMD when when it's all said and
done I think but uh definitely they're
they're not working with Nvidia ever
again
um which is I I think Nvidia is is I
know this is all PC talk but it may bode
well for AMD in the long run if AMD is
very aggressive with their pricing
you know they could end up finally
stealing some market share from from
Nvidia so we'll see what happens
yeah so I mean what what we'll do is go
ahead and move on to the next topic I
ain't trying to keep you guys here
forever and we're going what we're going
to talk about is next year being the one
of the greatest if not the greatest year
of gaming like it's it's kind of crazy
like I was sitting there I was looking
over the next six months just from today
and that's not even including like
Starfield uh anything coming out the
later 2023 just like the beginning of
2023 is some of the most stacked gaming
I've ever seen uh we'll start with dirt
man what what do you feel about this and
you know I want you to put on like what
your top three most anticipated games in
2023 are too oh man uh if you can't
think of three just think of one
well
so far it's it's looking stacked right
off the top of my head um
oh wait a minute like list of protocols
this year right yeah that's this year
I'm sorry
um you know I'm looking I'm me
personally I'm definitely looking
forward to
Starfield
um and yeah
I don't know man like help me out with
some of the games he's dropping oh the
Resident Evil remake Resident Evil
before remake you know I I'll never
finish residue before
so I'm looking forward to going through
that one playing that one um man we got
the dead dead space remake we got I
don't care about Zelda
um oh my God yeah I don't care about
nothing so let's talk about that's what
I'm talking about nothing Nintendo I
don't give a damn I'm trying to play
that I don't care about Zelda Mario link
man I want to play a game called Kirby I
don't care about none of them uh there's
no switching your house no no
I've had light switches
[Laughter]
I kept it like this back when I was 12
years old
I was the second guy like hey I only had
that Nintendo stuff over here no but um
man that's what yeah
exactly no but yeah uh I can't think of
everything like I'm hyped rare fall of
course because I'm Arcane fan oh we got
four Subs like Final Fantasy uh it's
crazy it's crazy
on the top of my head what else is like
what some other games that's I mean okay
I could I got a list up so Suicide Squad
all right so in January there's four
spoken and Fire Emblem engaged okay so
what is remote you should have started
with fire and then with the force ball
could you started off like really bad
hey look for smoking looks good to me I
don't know what y'all talk about anyway
uh I'm actually interested in this other
game this is kind of in the uh uh it's
called it's called um
it's Deliver Us bars which is like a
sequel to
um what was that game called Deliver Us
the Moon it was an indie though oh yeah
yeah
that's this that sequel was coming out
in February I'm I'm hyped for that
um Dead Island 2 in February Hogwarts
Legacy
like a dragon
um
octopath traveler 2 uh Destiny's
delightful for for Forte and attic
because you know they're the only ones
that care about that uh a Resident Evil
4 remake in March I then this is the
rest of the year Alan Wick 2. oh I
forgot about that our creators
Assassin's Creed Mirage Atlas Fallen uh
the avatar game that massive
entertainment and Ubisoft that for some
reason I feel like it's gonna be a
failure like a straight back I don't
know why yeah it's definitely going to
suck uh I could agree there's so much
here
um and that man said pick three games
man though yeah I can't do it no I'm
just going through the list that this
Final Fantasy 7 rebirth Final Fantasy 16
Flintlock there's just a lot of games
coming out next year is that
realistically enough games to play like
it really is like next year
is so stacked I don't know if you've
released the complaint and of course
Donna Taco with the smoke five dollar
Super Truck for Donald otaku dirt's
still mad that was Splatoon 3 is better
shooter than Halo infinite a Legend of
Zelda tears of the King Tears of the
kingdom is gonna sweep 2023. hey yo I
believe that second part that first part
is
you talking about Splatoon not being one
of the best shooters that came out
that's not what he said
what did he say yeah he was a better
shooter than Halo infinite it might be
talking about the game right now you can
talk about Halo content lack of content
but you can't say that gameplay is in
solid I guarantee you Splatoon got more
content I
just said you can say what you want to
say
Halo infinite isn't better than Splatoon
3 right now okay
that's my favorite franchise of all time
and they disappointed me to the point
where I just can't play that game you
you might be a Halo Stan but you're
hatred for three four three is so strong
but it overwrites everything oh it does
I I can't I can't do it you know what we
didn't talk about Jedi uh Star Wars Jedi
Survivor oh man that's gonna be a good
game too oh BG in the chat Splatoon 3 is
fire
it was crazy I don't [ __ ] believe
that man that man doesn't sound like so
that sounds awesome
I think I think his wife got on his
account and said something
is actually we sure that's you be here
or is that or is that the missus huh but
you're shooting pain at people
what's your point
is you're shooting pain at least at
least at least when I shoot somebody in
Splatoon three the bullets go where they
supposed to go bullets what bullets
at least there's hit registration in the
game sir Hey listen I'm not at least
Halo doesn't have issues
because it does clearly it does so I'm
not wrong
I need your honest opinion gameplay to
gameplay what's better Splatoon or Halo
infinite gameplay to gameplay not the
concert the game itself like playing the
game oh best multiplayer game I'm trying
to tell y'all man oh he he he's he's
with it he's with it man I feel like
he's being like BG blink twice if you're
in danger
listen man that multiplayer is actually
really good man people people sleeping
on that splatfest that's about to happen
all right yeah I thought I would never
hear that sentence before hey hey hey
hey yo Forte listen to yourself man
listen man
yes sir hey but you know what but let's
be for real this is this isn't just
being this is a cap this is just for
real 343 has let people down so much on
Halo where they'd rather go play
something like Splatoon where you paint
I've heard two two people say I heard
what three people say that you Donna
taco and Flame okay
so that's four exactly exactly what is
so good about the gun play in Splatoon
3. somebody explained it to me like
break it break the gun play down like
with a handgun how was it good
oh
cat so go
me what makes platoon so fantastic so so
imaginary so amazing no no no I just
think because it does what it's it it
does what it sets out to do better than
most other games decided what does it
mean in the lane that that game is
in a competitive environment that game
sets out to do what it does when it
comes to like movement when it comes
down to strategy and getting around the
map it actually works very very well
because not only are you painting the
world to actually uh attack other people
you're using the paint to be able to
move throughout the environment way
faster than anybody else
because that's something they always
been doing find it even more inside of
the new one and then they actually made
a competitive scene in it and the game
actually is really really good when it
comes to that
I played Splatoon 2 I think like and I
remember like yo dirt you can literally
go under the map like in the with the
with the paint itself so you mean to
tell me that people complain about
something like like uh where you could
see through walls and stuff but you can
literally go in the floor and no one has
issues
that's something that that wasn't that
was something that was
um
was made and inspired in the game from
the very beginning you've always been
able to do that I mean isn't the same
isn't that sense in in Last of Us and
stuff in the game too what and people
complaining about talking about right BJ
it's about pain think about it it's just
like looking like like it's like if
you're sitting here it's just like if
you're sitting this is not Allen Iverson
talking about practice hey we talk about
paint we talk about pain it's pain not a
rifle
[Music]
you know someone had a good question to
chat is it 60fps
oh please say it because if it isn't it
if it is that I'm roasting it's six it's
60. it's 60.
it's fake 60. that's probably one of
them
very uh no no no I was thinking about
the single player motion of it but I
think the single player 60 but the
multiplayer is definitely 60.
it's definitely oh my God you guys are
ridiculous we're gonna move on yeah yeah
I'm trying to tell you listen it is
nothing wrong with under listen the fact
the game so the game is sold out
everywhere yeah you can only get digital
copies of the game I'm sure it is it's a
Nintendo game you know what you know
what it is dirt dirt
Forte is hiding all the copies of
Splatoon in the back exactly he's
calling the other Game Stops yo we gotta
make sure we gotta make the illusion
that this game's selling well but put
this in the back but look at this but
look this we were talking about this
earlier look at the chat it's people
that's making fun of it because they
just don't either understand it or they
don't like it the fact that the game
there is so many people that actually
like the game
is the crazy thing because like nobody
thought Splatoon 3 was going to be this
amazing thing everybody thought it was
going to be an iteration and something a
little bit better than the last one but
they actually innovated and did some
stuff different that people wanted to
see inside of it and that's why a lot of
people are enjoying it and if you're not
as if you've never played Splatoon
you're not one of those people that's
been indebted and playing that type of
game yeah you'll probably be thinking
like dirt is right now like we're
painting houses man what what is this
about but it actually is a it is
actually a really really fantastic game
and there's a reason that you know I
think this is going to be the first
Mainline Nintendo game where the
multiplayer actually really really
functions to the point where people want
to play it and that's what's going on
right now
okie dokie buddy
come up to us you know what they're you
come over to the crib come over to the
crib we'll put we'll put it up on this
on the 55 inch well you know it's gonna
look a little blurry because all
Nintendo games look very at 55 inches
but uh we go we're gonna put it up don't
do it there he already talked about
splatting people and stuff over there
and deal with any of that man don't just
whatever you do man whatever you do
don't go in the basement with that man
don't go don't go in the basement with
that man is to play with paint yeah I
don't think that works
split tacular or whatever the heck you
just said and everybody in the chat was
like yeah shout out to whatever
something yeah yeah you don't want any
of that dirt yes okay so you shout out
to the homeboy Donna taku with the 10
super he said Splatoon 3 gameplay is
great there is so many weapon Styles and
ways to play the game only people who
never played the game hate on it and
that's hashtag facts and I'm trying to
tell you that's what it is
if you never if you didn't play Splatoon
you don't understand none of the stuff
that's happening and you hey look I I
will play Splatoon when they add like
real bullets and then executions I want
to take them characters I want to be
able to like kick your character execute
someone that like splatters in the paint
like imagine like hold on hold on hold
on imagine some imagine some Mortal
Kombat like like finishers on the on
these characters made out of paint like
you punch them in the face and they're
and it's like their head just has a a
hall of paint dripping
rip off the arm and beat them with the
other arm I want to be able to sneak up
behind someone else and just snap their
neck like roll
like this is all fun yeah you know yeah
we're having fun with cracking jokes
I've never played Splatoon I don't play
Nintendo games right but
um they started last week if you guys
don't notice by the last week Donald
inflame they were just talking trash
about you know Splatoon 3 blasting halo
three I mean Halo infant I'm sorry so
look man
I don't care
about Splatoon I don't care about any
Nintendo IP I just don't I have respect
for Nintendo for what they've done for
the industry but me did now this is just
me I don't know earlier when we was
talking about Nintendo games you you was
definitely clowning and do you really
respect Nintendo or are you just
scattered the Nintendo Fanboys
listening they might break your legs
more than PlayStation Gamers did oh my
legs is just healing dirt dirt
PlayStation guys broke my legs last year
that's why that's why he never left that
that's why Dart never lets you see his
house that's why he always has the
background because he knows he's like a
Nintendo dude see my background he gonna
he gonna try to find out where I live
I'm gonna open up the door it's gonna be
a Nintendo dude there with his switch he
gonna beat me to death with that switch
man my thing might know Nintendo fat boy
when I was a kid I was fighting that
console on the playground I was gonna
say I was one of the few Sega guys
because you know it was mostly Nintendo
guys you know hey man anybody scared of
y'all
but we got Mario I said I got Alice kid
okay yeah okay I I lost that one but you
know
it's just you know we'll go ahead and
move on to the to the next topic I I
feel like when it comes to 2023 I just
felt because the only reason we're
moving on is because you guys completely
went on a complete side tantrum of
Splatoon try to hijacked the
conversation but it was it was too fun
to clown on uh uh on Splatoon so I
allowed it uh but you know I feel like
we can all agree that
it's going to be a good year as long as
nothing gets pushed back too much right
I think that's the key thing you know
what I think we can afford a couple of
those games to get pushed back not Xbox
because you know we need something yeah
yeah no more Xbox games puts back but I
mean yes
just knowing I know this is going to be
crazy to say but just off of the stuff
we know next year do you think there's
anything like definite that you would
think would take game of the year I read
it
Zelda Zelda is over here
you know and I don't have a rocker with
link or Zelda or any of them so you guys
don't think nothing has a chance no yes
I do it now I do what what do you think
he's gonna say star Phil star field
because this is the thing with this game
all they got to do is fix the issues
that breath of the wild one had which
was empty environments make it a little
bit more Fuller add some more
traditional dungeons to the game outside
of just the um the um the shrines
uh and that's really all they got to do
is cut and then kind of some people want
them to fix the animations on the
breaking of the weapons and stuff I
think that actually brings a little bit
more character to the game and stuff but
if they can fix just the environments
and add more classic dungeons this game
is going to be fired you know what I
actually I'm I'm gonna come give me a
switch man
you can play that's for two three hold
on man what's the trading value for this
[ __ ] right here
first of all you should have been gay
that bad about five dollars
so hold on dirt is that even an HDR pass
through one or is that just the standard
one I have I think it's HDR pass through
one I got this in 2017 does that okay
what's what's the trade-in man what's
the trade-in for it yeah I think it's
like 70 bucks on it
well that's just for the headset the um
the the the move controllers trade in
separately and I don't have those
wait wait so wait do you even have me oh
you have the camera do you have a camera
I do got the camera okay the camera
trades in separately too do you have do
you at least have the the cables for
that that thing yes yes I still got the
cable like all the cables you know how
some people come together without cables
I didn't know that this Xbox I was
rigging they had to have an HDMI
like I remember correctly you guys will
take it but you you charge like a fee
don't you no no that's only if it's
defective they charge a fee if it's not
then they just take it
oh no they don't no we don't take it
without course you've got to buy the
chord so if I brought in an Xbox series
X right now you use you wouldn't take it
if it didn't happen I would I would take
it and I would tell you like bro you got
to buy this cable
this HDMI cable so pretty much pretty
much what you would do is uh hold up
hold up I don't I don't know I don't
know GameStop all right so I would have
to trade it in and then I would have to
the first I would have to buy a cord off
the trading value or do I have to buy it
first the answer no no you can buy it
could be all on the same transaction
they just deduct whatever the trade-in
cost I mean whatever the so cost of the
part they need is off of it so pretty
much it would just come off the price
naturally like I wouldn't have to
actually go out there and pick it out
like you were just naturally coming off
and you would do it yeah I would do all
that for you you know that's you know
some people probably be like yo let's
read this stuff I feel like no that's
too much work let's let's just free this
up
or I would tell you to go home and get
it how much is a power cord
seven bucks
that's not bad that's not bad
yeah I mean all the systems use the same
power cord at this point
why would someone trade in a system with
no power cord why would somebody trade
in anything without all the cables it
happens every day yeah I had the person
that came into the store the other day
was like hey can I trade in this play he
wanted to trade a PlayStation 5 here and
I was sitting there like
where's the controller it where's the he
was like I don't have it you don't buy
just a system no
I was like where did you get assistant
with no cables in my mind I'm you know
scenarios are kind of running at that
point all right you just stole it yeah
didn't like have time to grab the
controller cables
I can trade it in you just got to buy a
controller which costs like 60 bucks and
you got to buy a cable I said it's gonna
take about 100 off the price of your
trade-in and he was like so how much is
the trade in for I said oh 300. he's
like so what I get 200 in cash I said no
you get about 180 in cash because you
got to buy all the other stuff and he
was like okay he bought so hold up hold
up he definitely stole that oh yeah it
is absolutely yeah so hold on hold on
I'm curious I'm curious on this all
right this is fascinating to me like so
so you if I came in there yeah and I'm
sure it man I what happens
have you ever had to deal with like the
cops and stuff from stolen merchandise
like did the cops even come to GameStop
yeah they come they'll come if someone
makes uh someone is an idiot if they
still start forget and do it at a
GameStop like because that yeah I'm sure
that Gamestops have security yeah I'm
sure GameStop's definitely got security
cameras you know I I would take my you
know I'm not stealing stuff let me put
that out right there I take my chances I
take my attentions at a pawn shop you
know the odds of that place probably got
a security camera maybe don't but you
know that GameStop got a security camera
and you know you're gonna be the the
sore thumb sticking out when you come in
there with no controller no power cover
they'll be like yo
um he someone stole my Xbox series X
um I'm wondering have you had any
tradies like did they still everything
did they just steal the console yeah man
I sold I I took that like an hour ago
like that happens though bro that kind
of stuff forever I've seen it happen
oh that's crazy that's crazy all right
let's let's move on let's move on with
this way
oh GTA 6 leaks we got one hour and 28
minutes for the uh for the time stamp
Mafia yeah getting time stamps right
yeah because that that they'll come
after me man yeah man yeah so GTA 6
leaks
what do you guys think about the man
what's going on do you guys like what
you've seen yes well let me say this
first that's where you go because I'm
not gonna be that long I think it looks
fine right some people said it looks
better in the Saints Row right now right
at this current state he looks better
than stage row
which is funny but
um I'm a fan of the franchise I'm a fan
of campaigns and I don't play the online
but I think as early as that was I
thought it looks pretty good especially
in that Diner scene that when I I don't
know if you guys saw that guy yeah were
you actually easy
I know that they're going to capitalize
the hell on that stuff and they should
no but I think it looks great uh I hate
to hear people say oh it looks like crap
around the game is two years out will
you stop it and this is Rockstar
all right this is Rockstar you know
Rockstar has a track record just stop it
you know I'm tired of saying people oh
that game looks like crap stop it I mean
again you guys two more years yeah
exactly bro look that it looked it
looked pretty good for a game that's not
releasing for at least two years exactly
especially considering they do not
actually like add in like all the
textures and and all the detail like
they don't care about the visuals when
they're trying to develop like game
systems and design and balance the game
all that stuff isn't isn't important
until the end so when people uh same
thing happened with redfall when they
first show The like that the stuff the
streets of screenshots of redfall leaked
the people yeah oh my God look at this
look at this is this it is this it's
just like yo one you weren't supposed to
see that right
like go after the developer in the game
if they actually show you the game and
it looks like crap they didn't show you
anything someone stole this and leaked
it it would like facts yay so it's like
it's not supposed to be polished up and
looking like a the hottest trailer
you've ever seen there's just there's so
many uh I'm sorry to say it like this
but dummies out here this gaming you're
right
it's it's a lot it's like I I posted a
couple days ago it's a lot easier to get
a lot of a lot of uh influences and
stuff to come on a podcast and talk
about games that it is to play games
like a lot of these people just don't
play games they just don't and then you
got then you got people like kissimmu
that refuses to play uh knock knockout
guys with me like he just refuses he
won't play fortnite with me but guess
what he will play he'll he'll play he'll
play Peppa Pig Peppa Pig man you know
what's funny every time this dude hits
me up like yo make a [ __ ] fall out kid's
food in the chat
yeah what's funny zombie Ass could spoof
out Fall Guys yeah Fall Guy I popped in
a party three times yesterday that was
like Smooth play fall guys with me no
play Fall Guys now and I'm sitting there
looking at the stuff this man's playing
and I'm like why can't you play fall
guys because I'm busy
busy man
what's funny is you you know Forte got a
habit of jumping in the chat
and they're just disappearing for three
hours
totally talking about the party yeah
jumping in the party yesterday and your
people say I'm guilty for that too
no no you're guilty for jumping in the
party and then leaving without saying
anything I'm guilty of jumping in saying
hi then taking my headset off and zoning
out on something else on my PC for three
hours I feel like that's better though
like at least I'm not in the party and
people trying to talk no no no no if I
but if I'm not but see it's easy to say
that oh he's not there he's doing
something you on the other hand
literally coming to party hi everybody
and then two seconds later oh attic
leaves the party and I'm like what was
the purpose of that Elisa said hi some
people don't even get that well that's
true that's true at least you're not
well you at least you're you're somewhat
respectful but at least say bye to
people like I used to tell someone used
to come and say slow but just say bye
you know the funny thing is people can
say what they want about smooth you know
how he's uh you know bad at Games Etc et
cetera that dude plays everything like
it like from the trash to the gems to
the gym trashes like this is
oh you don't want to look at that so you
have to smooth man
what's funny is why one of the homies
out there when when the like those damn
opponents just trying to beat our legs
in last generation someone was out there
fighting a good fight shout out to
smooth what's funny is smooth that that
dude that when you try to to do a good
month on gamer score he's winning by
like 10 000 points
he only got he only got 15 000 this
month
oh 1500 only 15 000. damn that's pretty
good
yeah no there's been time where I've
seen smoothly like 15 20 000 in one
month oh yeah yeah that's because he he
literally went out there and bought the
two dollar gains off what's that one
developer that you the people look up
anytime that developer drops the game
they say they just search for that
developer in the let's move those so
what's that developer we know we know
you know don't try to act like you don't
know you literally just searched that
developer's name into something new pops
up it's like two dollars that you buy it
it's like weekly it's like weekly it's
you know what's funny like my girl
wanted some quick gamer score because
she just started and we just went to
smooth gamer score gamer card that's all
we had to do we looked through all the
games the recent games we played and if
I saw a thousand I click in and said a
minute there was one time I literally
clicked the dial a game that he got a
thousand Gamers score and it said he
played that game for a minute it took a
minute to get all thousand Gamers and
what game was that
hey what's funny is like it was pretty
much like a
East Asia soft that's what it's like
yeah that's not the name of it East Asia
sauce wait that's the name of it that's
right I think it is
wow that's real
I added was exaggerating no he really
knows one see it's the actual publisher
it's an actual puzzle wow it really is
uh East Asian shop publisher wow yeah
and all those games take like two
minutes 20 minutes tops to get the full
one down okay hold up Smooth you're
completely derode the podcast but it's
okay man it's okay because we we gotta
look at this like this is crazy let me
show you guys what this game is this
publisher is I gotta put the actual
screen here it is whoa don't don't go to
the website
don't do it
I haven't click transition don't don't
put that over here you do that but do
not put their web page on the screen I
made that mistake and I'm not I'm never
going back I don't see anything bad whoa
yeah
we ain't talking yeah
hold on wait I gotta look at this now on
my phone no don't don't do it I'm
telling you dirt
just just trust you don't want to lose
don't be telling me you played that game
I just saw
oh man oh Say It Ain't So Smooth all
right so you know let's go ahead and
move on uh there ain't really much to
talk about GTA 6. we just got to see
more of it you know I I hope that the
person uh I think they already caught
him didn't they person who did it all I
think they already caught him
the FBI was looking into it um because
he's he's actually hit a number of
different companies uh out there I can't
remember all the companies that he's hit
but uh Rockstar definitely was not the
first
and yeah so the federal authorities are
in on it now so they will eventually get
help because they they know they have
ways of doing things that aren't really
much of public knowledge so
it's crazy man
all right so let's go ahead and get on
with the last topic man we're at an hour
and 37 minutes hour and 37 minutes I
think you know probably talk about this
for 20 and then we'll be up out of here
uh and I'm putting the the time stamps
in 37 minutes so there you guys go no no
no no attacking me no attacking me uh so
we've been seeing more psvr too I'm
pretty sure that I don't care about it
at all but I I think you know dirt had
one so I'm assuming he gonna get it
blood and Truth was an amazing game on
psvr
loved it because so why won't you buy
for blood and Truth too
is it gonna if they announce it maybe I
will
um listen I
was a huge the getaway fan right
part one was awesome part two was and
they were developing one for part three
then they canceled it I say damn it
love to get away
so the blood of Truth was kind of like
another getaway game but it was in VR so
I loved it but I don't I don't think I'm
gonna get PSV on too bro because
it's an add-on that's probably going to
be 500 plus at least 500 minimum 500 I
actually for some reason what they're
saying I'm thinking like 650. I don't
know why six six fifty no way I I don't
know did you see the stuff that they
were talking about I did all right bro
that's gonna be this that's gonna be
funny if they charge 650 for uh an
add-on where you need a day of PS5 first
off
so it's technically an add-on
all right all right so 500 minimum what
are we going to do is we're gonna watch
this minute game a minute trailer
uh and I think you know we're gonna go
over one by one with this minute trailer
because I'm curious what you guys got to
say here's what you guys got to say
all right so
because I personally feel like when I
see this
this is not cheap like
Whoever likes VR and I know there's a
lot of you and I know a lot of people
really
Captivate with the VR stuff they about
to get you let me tell you they about to
get you I mean 500 isn't cheap and I do
believe it's a like I have a quest too
and it's a it's a more powerful VR
headset than the Quest 2 Quest 2 just
went up to like what 350 minimum for the
the smallest version I got the the stuff
up I didn't get the smallest one but not
the smallest but like the uh the
cheapest one but I if it went 500 it
would still be more expensive than a
Quest 2 yet still cheaper than say like
the the uh the valve index which is a
thousand
and the HT HTC Vive which I think is a
bit old
um and it probably is more powerful than
that but that that that Vibe is again
old so I don't know like I think I think
it would be weird for them to price it
more than the PS5
all right so I got I got it up on the
screen okay what we're gonna do
we're gonna go frame by frame we're
gonna read all these luxurious words
that they got going on here all right uh
and then then we're gonna respectfully
guess what this sucker gonna be because
this look is spooky there like as far as
like how much this thing's gonna be all
right so let's go in with this we don't
really need the sound
uh so obviously these controllers by
themselves going to be put in price
point
um
these controllers look do you think they
look quality you think they look like
they're gonna break after you step on
them once
okay
I like the way they look style yeah you
know yeah but honestly like the look of
it yeah
let's talk about the controllers are
coming with it yes not because like when
I got my VR mines didn't come with a um
with the those dog crap move controllers
this might be damn
wow all right all right so all right put
in the chat and we're gonna ask both of
you what do you think these controllers
are going to cost individually like if
you break yours if you had a kid step on
them uh you know I have a little girl
a hundred dollars each yeah yeah oh yeah
for a replacement I don't think you're
lying about it think about how much your
dual sense cost was like 70 bucks right
70 80 yeah that's probably more advanced
than a dual sense so yeah I'm gonna
think about a hundred dollars
oh I feel like you you're so you just
took your soul dirt I'm just thinking
like
all of this
if that's true what you guys are saying
what slow-mo just said that controller
could possibly be a hundred dollars a
piece not together you think a piece
you got to think Elite controllers by
themselves cost 180.
that's a 200 contrary if people ain't
gonna people ain't averse to spending
all right so so all right so you guys
think this is a hundred bucks that's a
hundred bucks right off the bat it's not
even the actual thing now keep in mind
they're gonna probably take these at a
loss I do not see them making money off
the VR all right so let's get like like
in the whole package that you buy you're
gonna get it all together and it won't
be like okay well we spent you know this
is individually it's this this this and
this so you're gonna have to spend 650
right it'll be like you're getting it
all together it's a package but if you
gotta replace something okay we're gonna
give you that full on price if you had
to replace like a a broken a broken
controller or something you gotta
remember the the old the move
controllers brand new to replace those
were a hundred dollars for the two
all right so someone in the chat said
150 for the pair do you think that's
realistically I can see I can see 150
foot a pair I think that can be I think
that might be something they do take a
little lost on Accessory but but you
have to buy the pair
yeah Bob they would be bundled together
yeah yeah I could see that probably
because they don't sell because they
didn't sell the last set like they
already sold it in a pair they didn't
sell them separately you could you could
only buy them you can only buy them
second hand uh by themselves all right
so this uh the actual part that looks
like an Oculus
what's that gonna be what how much you
think that gonna be Chad how much you
think that gonna be guys it's big and
you know we're obviously okay hold on
that because we got to go through the
features that this unit gives you all
right so obviously you get the
controller and the actual head unit
uh it's looking like you know they're
going through a lot of graphics with
this uh what's funny is if you look on
here it says at the bottom not actual
gameplay
it's different doing it on like regular
games but they're doing it on a VR and
putting it at the bottom they're making
this look all pretty and then like okay
for legal purposes but not actual
gameplay it's like that's the whole
point of this experience
oh yeah oh no bro I don't know
um all right 4K HDR display listen man
you know how much does the index cost a
thousand dollars yeah
it has better resolution than the valve
index and the index costs a thousand
dollars I don't think PlayStation gonna
charge somebody a thousand dollars
consist of two uh 20 by 24 L OLED
displays so that's where each eyeball
but to also also to keep it in
perspective even though the valve index
is a thousand dollar VR headset
um The Quest 2 has higher resolution
than the valve index and that's 350
something so it's just it's all about
like the full package of quality and I
mean it's definitely you know psvr too
yeah the the index the all the parts you
get with the index is like incredible
like nothing's cheap in that thing
everything's made of metal so you're
paying if you're paying for the build
quality also when it comes to the index
uh and the index has been out for quite
a while now so you expect newer stuff to
be uh probably cheaper the valve just
charges the thousand dollars for because
they know they can charge a thousand
dollars for the people who buy it plus
it's predominantly always only for PC
but um yeah this thing is still going to
probably cost 500 at least five
the last one was three 350. yeah I was
just about to ask you that because I got
mine on sale it was some type of Game
Stop sale over the holidays and uh
2017 yeah 299 was the sale I got that
yeah I got it for 2.99.
but the regular price was what three
weeks three three well 3.99 then they
dropped to 50 bucks so okay 350 now yeah
so that one was 400 yeah it's definitely
uh so and that was the bundle with the
headset the cameras and everything let's
finish these the the these these
keywords they love throwing out here uh
it's pretty cool but they're using the
actual you know developers I actually
think this is the wrong way I think that
you know they might have something
similar that was the PSP area where it's
like I personally feel like to make
these type of games successful you need
to make to make games that make sense to
these type of games in general you know
what I'm saying like when you make a
handheld you kind of want to stick to
games that are good on handheld that
makes sense playing on the go like
sports games Pokemon you know uh that's
just my me personally
yes sir yes sir all right so hold on
let's keep going let's keep going you
know okay eye tracking now I don't know
how advanced this eye tracking is but it
looks pretty advanced
oh man you can't nobody The Quest 2 has
eye tracking okay so but the quest two
they just raised it a hundred dollars
too it's 3.99
what the big boy
all right so now I don't even uh
rendering what is that
motivated rendering is that what it's
called yeah what is that
does anyone know no no
I you know I heard someone explain it
once before and I didn't forgot so sorry
I think that just you think they're
throwing out words that just look nice
no no I mean it's definitely weird
they they wouldn't like say it's in
there that wasn't in there
um I I just looked it up it's it's uh
someone said think VR is a rendering
it's a rendering technique
maybe like a form of uh fos I don't know
this is what it does so when you're
let's say you're you're you got the
headset on and you're looking around in
the world everything that's in your uh
uh per peripheral vision is like reduced
image quality to allow more uh more of
the image that you're looking at to
actually have higher quality and sharper
visuals and stuff you know what that you
know what that makes me feel that sounds
expensive but we're gonna keep going
sounds expensive focus on Vivek detail
that can mean a variety of things it's
not really too much on that 110 field of
view what they so didn't they just have
some feature revolved around this and
now they're gonna now they're like even
specifically saying it so that kind of
feels like you already did it in like
the the you know the the technical word
so why are you repromoting it as like a
casual word does that make sense Loma I
think they're doing it just for the
simple fact because the fact they're
padding they're padding the promotional
that well that too but that field of
view would actually help with motion
sickness too because if you're pulled
back further yeah from the actual screen
that was the biggest thing about the
last one with the field of view being
like I think it was like 80 something
you were so close to everything
everything felt like it was moving
faster than the need to in front of you
and that's what really gave people
issues this will pull it back further so
use it on top of the faster frame rate
that you're getting per eye and the fact
that field of view is pulled back more
oh so pretty you'll be able to deal with
it a little bit better pretty much what
you're saying is like the actual they'll
be like like complete like looking
around motion is that what they're
saying okay it'll be it'll be widered
compared to what it used to be all right
so here's where things get nice nice and
nice and spicy finger touch detection
which that's that's not too big I'm
pretty sure that the Oculus has that as
well uh where it gets interesting is
when they go into stuff that's just a
dual sense here in a second uh uh
Tempest 3D audio tech that's cool for
immersion but once again hey hey uh Hey
Dart what does that sound
expensive it sounds expensive I got you
dirt I got you if you thank you brother
if it's 15 extra and a controller is
probably 30 extra in the headset we got
a member chat for 15 months stop
stitching Forte you know hey hey ain't
here for stitching in this place man
okay we're gonna keep going with that
and what's funny is they keep using the
same game to promote everything except
for uh
well I well add it I don't know if you
saw what Yoshida said because they ain't
gonna have nothing but Indies on it
scrapes
okay a headset feedback what is this I
don't know what this is
oh it's going to vibrate okay so it's
gonna like vibrate your forehead it's
gonna get your damn headache y'all
that's the only half that you can get
I'll pass no no then the controller has
a haptic feedback
oh the aim is going to be rough I
already kind of feel this kind of rough
to aim with like the qx2 controllers
already imagine you acting like all the
super let's haptic feedback I'm trying
to aim yeah already messing everything
up man that'd be kind of rough look at
the diagram they give for like like the
muscles on your yeah on higher up in
your arm like when he actually clicks
the feedback it's like it's destroying
it
it's like yo that don't sound very pilly
but it is what it is okay so this is the
new Walking Dead game which is already
on Quest it's nothing you know
spectacular but this is a good game
people love this Game responds to your
actions
and then they have uh adaptive triggers
a a dart what does that sound like
it's not like it's so expensively
for uh attention you can feel
uh
it's it's just crazy man and I think
that's solid trailer all right so
like the game I have that's what's up
senator
so let's go let's go over let's go over
here chat
let's put a number on the actual helmet
The Mask without anything extra you know
for instance if I walked in the Game
Stop would try to sell this no wires
what's what's Forte gonna make me put on
top of this that I'm gonna get so uh
someone says 600 you think this thing's
gonna be 600 nah okay it's a fourth time
what you think just the the helmet's
gonna cost
450 450 oh that 450 450 with everything
uh Dart
[Music]
how much is the helmet
we're about to go the whole thing like
if they're not going to sell it
separately but obviously they're not
going to sell it separate right oh just
oh if they just we're talking about a
scenario where
the knife comes into your game we're not
talking about the thief scenario I want
to know what you guys think individually
what these things are gonna cost like
what they cost them I'm gonna say 300
300 that's what I think too 300 I think
that's one Z the helm is 300 The Joint
the controllers are yeah okay 150. so
you're saying 450 for the actual unit
what the whole thing you got it you got
to remember you got the camera too I
think I'm thinking I'm thinking this
thing six I'm thinking this thing six I
just thought about the camera you gotta
yeah I didn't think about the camera
either the camera is 60 bucks uh this
thing is six all day long 550 Brands
I think they'll do I think they'll do
five put it put it put it in there how
much you think this this thing's gonna
cost like the whole the whole bangus man
the whole English I'm starting to think
that foreign
you can find me in slow-mo's backpack on
DPS podcast every Thursday night 9 p.m
it would actually be on his channel
um this week coming up it's gonna be a
great time but for myself gaming Forte
Everywhere YouTube Twitter Xbox Live and
Playstation if you love that Destiny
content come through your boy's been
dropping videos weekly on it every time
yeah I just dropped one today but uh
yeah definitely come through check it
out and other than that man have a great
week enjoy your games and enjoy that
Splatoon three because oh come on man
hey hey man cut his mic off at it oh
he's already gone man I can't cut his
mic off he's already gone I'm out of
here y'all have a good night
the damage has been done like I can't
speak it I see now he's still talking
I'm a squid kid now oh come on man
what's going on
hey man nothing much man I appreciate
the invite thing I'm glad we were able
this time to get Forte's behind in here
too uh but like he said uh definitely
check us out tomorrow damage per second
podcast on my YouTube channel slow more
backslap at 9 00 PM Eastern Standard
Time people have a good time people have
as usual as usual we might have a little
special guest coming in with us to kind
of discuss the whole GTA uh uh situation
and you know maybe a developer that may
have some inside and that inside
information in regards to that but like
you know knowledge that us normal Gamers
wouldn't really have in regards to how
these things happen and how damaging uh
a leak like that can be but again uh
great shot it's that dude on Twitter
maybe
we'll see we'll see oh but no like yeah
come on through and uh as usual enjoy
your games and have a great night
and what what what what you what you
doing dirt what what what's what is the
the community of dirt man what's going
on with you guys hey man right now I'm
just kind of just playing games at the
moment um
check out last Monday's episode of wbg
we had a great time I'll leave the link
in the chat we had a great time we was
talking a lot of trash
um you know just had a fun show man so
um check it out when you guys get the
chance and that's about it brother I'm
hoping to drop some type of content
within the next couple days
but I need some to talk about that
interests me I'm tired of talking about
crying Jim Ryan so crying he ain't
crying that much man you gotta gotta
spam the chat you can't put it in there
once yeah yeah I'm about you gotta spam
it man you gotta spam it like I said man
go go to both of these people's podcasts
uh slow mo and Forte they uh have you
guys ever gonna make an actual I know
you made the channel why is it the
podcast on the channel yeah
because we we already kind of like got
people invested with Channel memberships
and everything and so what we're doing
is that we we're we're gonna be you're
making an eclipse start looks like well
more it's gonna be more than that
because we're gonna go live on it when
we play games together too it's just
getting a forte to actually sit down and
play a game sometimes it's a little a
little difficult but uh no I mean we're
gonna do we'll be doing live content on
it and and other like uploaded content
that's just not clips from the podcast
let's just going towards it so you just
look out for all that uh first of course
it was supposed to already drop a video
this week he didn't but yeah anyway so
when they doing his job
you know I'm just just saying look it's
it is what it is but don't look um but
we check out that uh that link to uh the
damage for a second podcast link um I
will actually find it in a second yeah
you might want to actually put it in the
chat
yeah yeah I'll get it up there but yeah
um
whose channels it on again this week
uh my channel okay yeah spam your
channel in there I don't know they they
they play musical podcasts I I don't
know why they do it but they do it it's
on one channel one week in the next
Channel both of them follow both of them
there you go that's the only way you're
gonna keep up to date on the bill on
both of them hit the Bell on both of
them yeah
if you pop up on one channel one week
and they ain't live they're pretty
consistent I don't think I've really
seen them miss too many shows chances
are you're on the wrong channel for the
week I think we've only missed uh one
week
um since we started doing the show yeah
nice yeah man that's nice it's all about
it
yeah it's like when I started wbg and
February
of 2020 you haven't missed one so even
when I had Kobe I was stuck in the
basement anyway I said he was doing
stuff on code right yeah huh you was
doing your podcast so why haven't
covered yeah I was stuck in the basement
anyway I might as well do it because
because you know my PC and stuff is down
here so I said hell might as well
because I had Kobe but at that time I
was vaccinated I mean I was last I was
fully vaccinated but it was still and I
still seen it yeah my symptoms wasn't
minor symptoms yeah you just felt like
you felt like crap but you know it's uh
yeah I feel that I feel that I'm right
here might as well do it foreign
yeah I I was quarantined when I had
covered in my basement as well for like
a full week but I only really like felt
the effects of covet for like two days
before I was diagnosed and then two days
after so like yeah it was like five days
to be just sitting in the basement
playing video games yeah that's pretty
much what it was and watching oh 80
movies that's why I play video games
yeah as like I said I appreciate
everyone for coming through uh you know
we had uh up to like 320 or something
like that in the threes that's all I
know is in the threes uh definitely hit
that like button man I don't even know
what it is at the moment I'm not on the
screen uh but you know you guys came
come through every week man I feel like
addict show grows weekly I really
appreciate all the support you guys do
we will most likely be doing a community
uh an IOP Community today this this
Saturday I did want to do fortnite as
part of the community thing but
unfortunately
I wasn't able to you have to get
approved like a special program to be
able to do that and it's weird because I
still can't get into it like I don't
know I it's it's weird how they do
things it's it's shut down right now so
you can't even apply
I don't know but we'll figure something
out there is a game that is coming out
it's called like uh it's it's like a
pirate game that would play the Pax I
did send off uh an email to try to get
me like 10 codes so we can all play it
and whoever wants to show up it just
depends if that happens you know we're
gonna have fun regardless you know even
if we have to play Halo and it's glitchy
self uh we're we're gonna have fun
regardless but I appreciate it for
coming through play Splatoon three
that's what you said we are not playing
Splatoon three I don't know but we do
have we have that that wrestling game
whatever those things are called
which one I don't know the one that just
came out WWE 2K uh Rebel verse
one there's a rubble like the Battle
Royale
wrestling
it's weird it's like an arcady wrestling
game but it's like mixed with a bunch of
other stuff I don't know that's why you
said Russ that's the only wrestler game
after I've heard of them it's a 2K game
it's oh no it's a 2K game oh it might
happen yeah my WWE 22 yeah yeah it's a
2K game so you know we might play that
oh no you know I I'm being told that
people don't like the the previous Call
of Duty uh the the beta that's out and I
think that's out during that time too
but I don't even know if you could if
you could partner up with people playing
that game I'm not quite sure uh not
exactly qualified to do that stuff but
you know and you ain't never gonna catch
me on Call of Duty anyway so you know I
appreciate it for coming through and you
know we'll be back next week I I do plan
on doing a little bit better when it
comes to getting newer entities on the
podcast I want to really expand on that
I've reached out to like Colin Moriarty
I've reached out to him uh Jeff grubb's
going to come on eventually uh Jazz get
a little bit people of everyone uh I
know people on the channel are all I
call him uh I get you I feel you but I
don't care
I want different perspectives on the
show if you don't appreciate the man for
his political or gaming opinions that is
your opinion that's your right to have
that opinion but we will we won't come
in here and dictate how I run my show
and that's just a fair warning because I
know some of you like that I'm not
saying everyone I'm not even saying you
guys are in the chat I'm just saying
some of you real extra on trying to
demand who I have and who I don't have
on the show and I'm going to tell you
right now when you start seeing some of
these individuals come on the show
just neither watch the show or come next
week man because you you don't got to
watch every show if you don't like the
content that's going on currently you
can come back the week after I feel you
sometimes there'll be people on on
podcasts and I'm sure everyone here on
this on this panel can recognize that
sometimes you'll have people that you
don't really mess with on a podcast and
you like I see you next week like it
it's it's not a big deal man I ain't
gonna get upset with the one that wants
that doesn't want to watch a podcast
because someone they don't like's on it
because sometimes people if you don't
really generally don't like someone
sometimes that person just having that
person will ruin the mood and I get that
yeah just skip the week man I appreciate
it for coming through we will see you
next week and until next week this is
gaming addicts slow-mo back slaps and
dirt grickety and Forte is gone but I
appreciate you guys and we'll see you
next week and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna send you over there to fame's
podcast tell them over there tell them
the addicts sent you attic show sent you
guys uh it's like I said I appreciate
everything you guys do for us and until
next week we're out